this guy was the king of New York with
Mike Francesa for a long time
on WFAN he's Chris Russo still rolling
on Mad Dog sports radio sirius XM you
can hear his show Mad Dog unleashed
every weekday afternoon it's 3:00 and
he's on the MLB Network show high heat
with Christopher Russo and we say good
morning to Mad Dog hello foul how are
you totally
I've watched at nine million times it's
right up your alley
have you seen that Laurel Canyon show on
epics that two-part thing in the late
60s with music in Southern California if
you watch that again yes I have watched
it there's been a couple on that there
was a David Crosby has a bio yeah on him
as well about that whole region and all
the music that was birthed there and
Laurel Canyon man it's been good a jury
I can't and I'm a little too Yahoo's ten
years old with Woodstock Eddy Coleman my
pal was at Woodstock little too young
but boy oh boy I can't get enough of
that with you know the Byrds CSN of
course Morrison Jackson Browne who I
love anyway oh I can't get up I figured
you'd be into that because that's let up
you're out yeah
your first concert what was it first
concert was the outlaws no I'm sorry
Loggins and Messina at the herb at Siena
in 1917 poppy 1975 that was my first one
first time I saw Bruce was at the Palace
Theatre in Albany may of 1978 I was 18
and let's see the first time I saw the
who at the I saw the Hood Shang and I
saw a Rolling Stones a thousand times
but I missed the big one said I'd see
Grateful Dead
I did not see CSN you know I didn't see
obviously
Henricks or the doors I missed some of
those big ones but at least I saw the
WHO and a lot of stone I don't know if
you missed anything not seeing the
Grateful Dead just go to a Phish concert
and that's basically the same feeling
their dog yeah
but I know there was a period day I used
to love those concerts and I'm I kind of
wish I was around in 1969 because I
would have ventured to Bethel New York
and I would have been put out of here
for me and flung there with Woodstock
anyway where do you stay it wouldn't you
stand on the Jordan documentary I loved
it I mean I understand that he had final
say and everything else I mean I loved
it I thought the curve wand in Episode
nine was superb with his father you know
I thought the Pistons stuff was great I
did a lot of shows based on that on the
Monday with guests you know I did Rod
Thorn after the first one with thee and
la curry his first coach I did that's
two I did Kevin I did trip Yuka I know
he wasn't on the bad boys but he knows
the players I did that I mean I did Van
Gundy with the Knicks you know with the
whole Nick thing so I based a lot of my
shows and I know you did the same on the
Monday off the Jordan documentary I had
the director on and oh you did too so I
based a lot of it on that show these
shows that we have to do now without
anything to talk about and the Jordan
documentary gave me a lot of content and
you know you and I lived it I my kids
loved it my 18 year old and my 20 road
whoo huge basketball fans didn't see
Jordan play couldn't get enough of it
Sunday at 9 o'clock so that tells you
how good it was in my eyes would we
allow that player to exist today on and
off the court probably not you know far
as you know being up to his teammates
and you know sort of the you know not
saying anything with the racial
injustice going on it's a little
different today the game would be a
little different too I mean he'd
probably be better because you know you
wouldn't be able to bang him around so
much and you wouldn't be able to do some
of the things Detroit did and the and
the Knicks did and you know I did Bob
when so - here's a good story that
you'll like Danny before we do the
baseball I had Wenzel on because he
recruited him he was a Duke with Bill
Foster when Jordan was coming out of
high school and I asked Wenzel about it
and he first time he saw him at the five
star camp something else and Wenzel went
to South Carolina after the Duke days
and a tea with Foster and he recruited
Jordan and I said really
I mean he said yeah I got to go to
campus his to his parents came to
Columbia and it's funny we went to the
governor's house his mansion and he had
a basketball court and all Jordan wanted
to do is the 17 year old was take the
governors kids out and play basketball
in the basketball court honey governor's
mansion uh listen in my eyes it's not
even close he's the best player of all
time in my house we're talking to a Kris
Mad Dog Rousseau host of high heat on
MLB Network and of course Mad Dog radio
sirius XM we gonna have baseball yeah I
think yeah I think we're gonna have
baseball then I mean I don't think it's
gonna be a kumbaya moment necessarily
and I think that's what baseball needed
was none of this mistrust with these
negotiations right now and come out and
play July 4th with an 80 game season I
think that moment is past
I don't think we're gonna have that
obviously you can't get ready for July
4th these sides there's a lot of
mistrust here
I think they figure something out but I
think the moment where they can sort of
bring back America sports wise is past
which is unfortunate I think somebody's
gonna have to be the big boy in a room
somebody's gonna have to realize that
you know what for the good of the world
we're gonna have to come out and play
even if we have a deal we don't like and
I think that person's gonna have to be
the commissioner I don't think the
players are gonna budge off this you
know 100 percent I don't think the
owners are gonna sit there and be very
happy about giving up obviously with no
fans giving up you know certain
concessions as far as playing X amount
of games without any fans they can lose
money so it's gonna be up to the
commissioner basically throw the bone to
the players allow them to get the full
rated pay for the amount of games and I
think he's gonna have to say not 50
games because people are not gonna like
that but I think he's gonna have to sit
there and say all right we'll play a 65
70 games schedule will start July 10th
July 12th and away we go a painfull rate
I think that is we're on our way to as
far as this negotiation is yeah my
concern is not this year as much as it
is down the road when you get this
selected bargaining agreement if I'm the
players and now all of a sudden you get
this feeling of they want to
troll us with the salary cap and you
just start to hear things where and
baseball is not about it's about the
haves and the have-nots I mean we talk
about Mike Trout and Bryce Harper they
make all this money you know the
majority of your your baseball union is
making a million or less and it feels
like the owners are sort of catering to
them to say hey we want you guys to get
paid but these big ticket items don't
want to come back your thoughts on Nate
I think that was the day I was to pay
scale scenario which I think you know
didn't sit well with the players I think
your original point is a hundred percent
right I think we got major problems
after the 2021 season and at the
agreements up in December of that year
and I be shocked if you're gonna have a
lot of baseball right away after 2021 I
can see a long dispute this is another
reason why if Manfred gives them a
throws him a bone here gives them a win
remember they got beef family in that
last CBA you know and everybody knows it
so if he gives them a win maybe that
soothes some you know bitterness and
they get a little something done after
2021 but I do think you're 1,000% right
I think 2022 baseball you know I was
gonna have some issues we're not there
yet obviously and I gotta get through
this season first I do think your have a
year I don't think you're gonna have
fans and I do think that they need that
not Jam these games down the throat
we're gonna play 50 games that's it I
can't say that they got to make the
players feel at least have them by in a
bit so is why I think Manfred will be
the guy he'll be the big guy in the room
I don't listen
I'm usually Pro owner and I am here too
but I say two things that bother them
and I'll use it for both sides I don't
want to hear from Bill DeWitt I don't
want to hear from Tom Ricketts who's
said some things I don't want to hear
the guy from Arizona
who went on radio station saying you
know we don't have as much money as you
think I don't want to hear from them
because it was the ticket refund policy
you got to go through page 58 to get
your money back with the ticket refunds
which is a disgrace Danny yeah I mean we
know you're not gonna play games give
the money back and a lot of these teams
the maneuvering which I can't stand so I
don't hear from men but I also don't
want to hear from the players who you
know good
tell me on two things well we are taking
extraordinary risk by playing games well
that's the case well then why do is your
proposals on in 14 games they want more
games so you can't tell me it's a health
risk
if you want to 514 games and then I want
to hear the players Sean Doolittle tell
me while we're doing this for the future
player who comes into sport that's why
there's a Lana's saying they wanted to
know who could flood was if they fell on
him for crying out loud so I don't want
to hear from the owners about you know
how broke they are and I don't want to
hear the players telling me their Norma
Rae and Samuel Gompers
none of them care about the future
player and the order doesn't care nobody
you know look at Atlanta for instance
you know that get that beautiful
ballpark have you been with that village
around that ballpark in Atlanta yes from
they got shops restaurants and I'm sure
Liberty media and they own serious it's
a mess when you first started out when
you when your people are saying well you
got a voice that sounds like I think it
was George Vesey at the times it was a
combination Jerry Lewis Archie Bunker
and Daffy Duck now this is in the New
York Times that they're saying this what
did that do element to if you ever seen
that one appearance I did not let him in
the first one yeah he spent seven
minutes making fun of my voice look
honey they gave Donald Duck yeah you're
right
that voice you know it has always it
served me well once you get used to it
but you know here's the key then you
know this you did you have to be able to
make funny of yourself a little bit and
so you know listen make fun of me why
you want just put the radio tuned into
all other stations I work do you
remember your first show that you that
you and Mike co-host yeah oh I did yeah
I remember the first show I've ever ever
did as a talk show was in Jacksonville
in 83 and the boss's son work with me on
a Saturday morning he was in March of 83
and he was a big wrestling fan so that
was a disaster
I'll be talking Ric Flair quiet
first up the first show is with Mike was
in Labor Day of 89 and Brandon Steiner
of Steiner Sports brought over sweaters
to you know basically all the inaugurate
the first Mike in the Mad Dog Show and
all the FA n employees are in the studio
watching Mike and I start on that the
day after Labor Day remember that was
right after Bart Giamatti died so you
know we had a you know we had the Rose
thing and we had money so we had
something you know a terrible story but
we had a big topic that out of the gate
but that is where I remembered it was
the day after Labor Day and it was 1989
[Music]
knockers Danny
nobody had we had never done a show
together we didn't know each other that
well Franklin had screwed up his
contract the late Pete Franklin and he
left and mark Mason decided to throw
Mike and beyond together and you know it
was it was a different time were you
doing sports entertainment I think I
just got there I'd left CNN I didn't
start with Keith until a few years in so
because we used to have you on it you
remember at the Super Bowl yeah you were
always the first guest or week or NBA
Finals
I remember NBA Finals said I don't like
93 yeah yeah yeah you know we did the
Chicago oh all the time use that you
were a Big Mike in a mad dog fan and you
came on constantly yeah I thought you
were on right around the same time we
were so you started with old men a
little later
well I remember telling you that you
were working weekends at the fan yes I
was peeling off wallpaper in my house in
West Hartford and I was listening to dog
and my wife goes who is that and how did
he get that job and I said that's Mad
Dog Russo and she goes it that voice and
I said yeah I said but that is it's
different than other voices but she said
the first guy ever worked for was Jeanne
burns who was a great talk to host who
passed away he worked at RKO in Boston
or in New York and he hired me at a
iesson Orlando so did my guy who's
passed away - he was the GM and Dyer put
Bob Trumpy on here
and Cincinnati after Trumpy retired a
game of sports talk show on LW in
Cincinnati so he knew sports talk stuff
and they said the same thing Chris
listen your voice is a problem specially
in Central Florida you're in New Yorker
it's gonna take some getting used to but
you know you've got a goofy delivery
screw-up all the languages and all the
words yes just go on there and do a
sports talk show and we'll see what
happens you know it's funny the
inaugural I went down to Orlando in 83
to do two shows on the weekend as sort
of you know audition shows because they
were looking to hire a sports tour guide
during a week and the first day I went
down there they put me on Sunday night
eight to ten I did not get one call so
if you can do Sunday night in Orlando
Florida in 19 this would have been in 84
in 1984 without a call for two hours and
you can somehow get through the show you
can do sports or oh it's good to talk to
your dog you're the man how you doing
everything okay I haven't seen you in a
long time things good everything's good
everything's good no complaints I think
I saw you at the all-star game in DC was
the last time I saw last time and every
time I see somebody struggle with these
posts or laboratory championships on the
stage with all these players whether
it's football or basketball sit out
there and try to do shows was it easy
Hey well we'll come visit you one of
these days it's serious good boy Danny
that's a mad dog Russo
you can listen to him on the mad dog
Channel Sirius XM and also high heat on
MLB Network